I told secretary Austin this uh almost a
year ago if you do this I'm going to
block your generals and Admirals from
promotion I can hold just so many of
them if they bring them one at a time
they could get them all they want but
the problem is as you said they don't
want bad
votes the this that Senator tuberville
was referencing was the pentagon's
promotion of abortion after the Dos
decision well that was exactly two weeks
ago on this show and now Senator Tommy
tuberville has gotten Democrats to Cave
not on their position of course but on
holding actual votes due to the
extraordinary circumstances of Senator
tuberville's Reckless decisions
Democrats will take action Senator
tuberville is forcing us to confront his
obstruction head on joining me now is
Alabama Senator Tommy tuberville Senator
breaking just moments ago the Senate
confirmed General Charles Q Brown Jr to
be chair of the Joint Chiefs of Staff it
took a while but the truth is Schumer
had the power to do this all along what
is the grand standing all about we he
wasn't going to do it I forced his hand
what I did as I used a rule of the
Senate that's not used very often I got
17 Senators to sign on to a petition
then I took it to the floor and said I'm
going to do my own closure vote I'm GNA
bring my own vote up and Schumer says no
no no we can't let him do that he'll
grand stand on us we'll do it so I
forced his hand and and we're going to
do two more tomorrow which will be good
uh but still I have my holds on and
they're going to have to change this
policy we're going to go through a long
drown out process so you're pretty new
to the Senate how did you figure out
this well I got I got good people that
work for me you know it there's there
are a lot of good rules you don't want
to use them unless you really have to
but we got to the point Lord we needed
to confirm some people and Schumer he
wasn't going to do it he was just going
to let it all blow up and make us look
bad and so next week was going to be
tough because CQ Brown the new uh uh
chair of the joint Chief they were they
were going to put it on on the front
page every day that hey I was holding
him up because Millie's out next week so
it worked out that that got done all
right Senator here's what Schumer says
is going to happen at the end of all of
this
though these three Honorable Men will
finally be able to assume their
positions and the abortion policy that
Senator tuberville abhor will remain in
place Senator tuberville will have
accomplished
nothing did you accomplish nothing uh he
blinked and he knows now what did you
accomplish well accomplished number one
showed people what we're doing okay they
can do them one at a time and they can
do that we we taught Schumer how to go
back to the floor and actually bring
somebody the floor so we could vote and
confirm them uh I think a lot of people
thought hey I'm holding them up no
matter what no schimmer can bring them
up one at a time we'll probably vote for
most of them they'll get confirmed but
they've waited 220 days Laura to do the
first one 220 days they pushed all this
stuff back on me but now it's on them
people know now that they can confirm
them and so we'll just sit back and see
if he brings anybody to the floor on the
other issue that I think is really
sticking in the craw to use an Auburn
phrase of Republicans is what's
happening uh with the leadership in the
Senate which seems to be on issue after
issue at odds with core Republican
voters concerns whether it's on Ukraine
more funding the Border still not doing
enough to stop the madness there um you
know a lot of stuff on trade in China
what happening it seems like we're we we
don't have that leadership in the Senate
that we need we don't have any
leadership in the Senate we don't have
leadership in the white house or the
Pentagon you know the biggest problem we
have right now is not Ukraine it's the
Border La if we don't stop that the
American people you know if you're not
see those videos we're playing earlier I
mean that is a travesty it's awful it's
costing us millions of dollars billions
not Millions the taxpayers are having to
pay this and we we're going to be
overrun it happened to Europe and Europe
they regret every day now that they let
all these people come into their
countries because they've overrun them
they're going to do the same thing here
because we don't have any leadership at
the top well um Senator McConnell could
do a lot this about 10 Republicans could
do a lot more to stop the funding
Madness but it's not being done we look
forward to you fighting on that Senator
great to see you I'm not going to say
good luck to you this weekend no good
luck this weekend good luck hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else